Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, ihr Lieben. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Das hier ist Lokbuch Netzpolitik, Ausgabe Nummer zweiundzwanzig.
Ja, auch wenn man sich mal streitet, das lehrt uns ja die die Ponyserie, wenn man sich mal, wenn es einen Konflikt gibt,
Und äh es gab ja, wie wir in der letzten Woche berichtet haben, den Konflikt zwischen dem Friedrich, dem Friedrich, dem Argen Hüterich und äh der Sabine,
Oder wie auch immer, so, die hat äh die haben sich ja nicht einigen können über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, obwohl Mutti ja gesagt hat, wollen wir. Ähm.
Ist in Mutti es in Angela Merkel.
Mutti ist in Angela Merkel. Und äh jetzt ach ja, ach ja, die ist ja alles.
Muss ja die Internetfachbegriffe auch erläutern ja weil sonst wird's ja immer so ein bisschen schwierig.
Genau, also wir wir hatten das ja letzte Woche sehr weit ausgebreitet und heute ist der sechsundzwanzigste April und heute ist Stichtag. Ähm bis heute hätten die fertig sein müssen und siehe da, es ist tatsächlich.
Also wir reden, du setzt ja einiges voraus.
Ich setze voraus, dass die Leute die letzte Folge gehört haben.
Nee, das, das, das, das setzt du voraus, aber verstehst du? Das kann auch äh anders sein, ja.
Zeitung lesen.
Ja, na gut, ich erkläre trotzdem mal, es geht um die, unser Lieblingsthema, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und da ist jetzt die Frist ausgelaufen, die Frist der,
EU, die gesagt hat, hm, hier, hör mal, mach mal, sonst äh wedeln wir noch stärker mit dem Finger.
Genau und mit dem Finger wie heißt der dann in diesem Fall äh eine äh eventuell bis zu einer Klage vor den EuGH zu,
Geh hin.
Im Europäischen Gerichtshof.
Um dort Strafzahlungen herbeizuführen für das Nicht-Einhalten einer oder für das konsequente Verweigern des Umsetzens einer EU-Richtlinie.
Das war ja der große, der große Druck, den jetzt äh der ja vom Innenministerium, wie wir in Folge achtzehn berichtet hatten, herbeigeschworen wurde, um diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt endlich ähm,
in Deutschland einzuführen. So und,
Dann gab es ja die Situation, Leutehäuser Schnarrenberger hatte einen sehr äh sage ich mal äh Grundrechtsschonenden Vorschlag gemacht
Und ähm der wurde ja lange Zeit ignoriert und jetzt im auf den letzten Drücker irgendwie von Friedrich äh dann haben, hat er überall wieder dranschreiben lassen, doch hier alles sechs Monate volles Format und so weiter,
Darüber berichteten wir in Folge einundzwanzig und ähm.
Dann haben sie sich beide an einen Tisch gesetzt und äh siehe da, konnten irgendwie wenige Tage vor Ablauf der Frist sich nicht einigen. Ähm sodass jetzt diese Frist abgelaufen ist,
ähm es gab also der Punkt ist jetzt, jetzt sagt man also, ja offiziell, jetzt steht gerade in allen Zeitungen
das hat daran gelegen, dass die beiden sich nicht einigen konnten. Jetzt muss man natürlich das zumindest mal zeitlich
ins richtige Verhältnis setzen, den Vorschlag von Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger, den gibt's seit Ewigkeiten. Der galt nur immer als inakzeptabel,
oder oder es wurde einfach nicht diskutiert nicht angenommen von von der Union, von den relevanten Unionsvertretern so. Und,
dann baute Friedrich eben diesen Druck auf durch sein durch seinen Hilfesuchen im Prinzip sein Betteln, um diesen Mahn um diese Mahnung von der EU Kommissarin,
Und dann setzte er sich quasi selber unter Zugzwang und musste,
Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenbergers äh Vorschlag eingehen,
Und das hat er dann gemacht und hat da irgendwie dann noch beigeschrieben, ja und außerdem wollen wir das auch anonymisierungsdienste äh so eine Art Vorratsdatenspeicherung betreiben müssen.
Ähm und hat dabei offensichtlich nicht daran gedacht, dass das Telemediengesetz äh verlangt, dass es eine anonyme oder pseudonyme Nutzung immer äh gibt und dass auch selbst die EU-Richtlinie nicht
'ne Deanonymisierung bei solchen Diensten verlangt. Also da ist ja über die EU-Richtlinie hinausgeschossen
gleichzeitig äh ist die EU-Richtlinie ja oft Terrorismus und schwere Straftaten begrenzt. Und in Friedrichskorrektur von Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenbergers äh
Vorschlag wollte er das dann auch noch irgendwie auf auf schwere Ordnungswidrigkeiten ausweiten. Und da würde jetzt.
Mal Straftaten, sondern.
Genau, sondern sogar auch in den Ordnungswidrigkeitenbereich vorschreiten. Und in dem Fall würde das Bundesverfassungsgericht ähm,
das Urteil, was ja damals gefällt wurde, zur Ablehnung der ersten Vorratsdatensprechung in Deutschland, würde in diesem Fall einen Katalog verlangen, für welche Ordnungswidrigkeiten und welche Straftaten denn diese ähm,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung stattfinden sollte. Und einen solchen Katalog hat der Friedrich auch nicht geliefert.
So, das heißt, er hat seine Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht,
und was auch immer er gehabt hätte an dem an den Tagen, in denen er jetzt in so eine Sabine diskutiert hat, wäre ohnehin nicht vorlagefertig gewesen.
Und ähm er hat dann weiter darüber hinaus keinerlei Kompromissbereitschaft gezeigt.
Ähm und man muss ja sagen, so das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat vor vor etlichen Zeiten sein Urteil gesprochen, Sabine Läuthäuser Schnarrenberg hat seit etlichen Zeichen äh Zeiten
Seit ewigen Zeiten da diesen Vorschlag gehabt und er hat nie irgendwo drauf reagiert so. Und man kann im Prinzip froh sein, dass irgendwie jede Vermutung einer geschickten Strategie bei diesem Mann irgendwie widerlegt wurde
er hat's einfach also er ist wirklich derjenige, der seine Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht hat. Man könnte sogar sagen ähm man muss eigentlich ihm danken,
äh dass dass wir jetzt erstmal äh offensichtlich als Regierung die in die Regierung die Entscheidung getroffen hat, wir lassen es jetzt mal darauf ankommen,
was die EU macht, wir erinnern uns,
Die EU-Kommission kann sich da jetzt irgendwie in Bewegung setzen, ist ja aber selber noch gerade bei der Revision dieser Richtlinie. Es ist ja eine Änderung zu erwarten. Ähm oder zumindest eine, ja, es ist eigentlich eine Änderung zu erwarten dieser Richtlinie.
In welche Richtung?
Naja, wenn die je nachdem, wie die Evaluation ausgeht, sollte man ja hoffen, dass sie auf äh auf EU-Ebene auch nochmal anders diskutiert wird, diese Richtlinien. Gibt's ja durchaus
sehr viele Gegner, die da auch auf EU-Ebene vertreten sind. Insofern, so oder so kann man davon ausgehen, dass zumindest eine Änderung,
möglich ist. Ja? Und diese diese Richtlinie noch nicht in Stein gegossen ist, weil, wie wir auch gesagt haben, ihr Land ja auch schon ähm die Klage gegen diese Richtlinie am EuGH äh anhängig hat,
Das heißt, äh es gibt im Moment wenig, also auch aus ökonomischen Überlegungen, eigentlich wenig Grund, diese Richtlinie jetzt umzusetzen.
Noch dazu sehr interessant. Äh jetzt wird ja gerade in den äh in den in den Zeitungen groß diskutiert. Ja und bis zu dreißig Millionen Euro im Jahr Strafzahlungen könnten auf Deutschland zukommen,
Da ist äh schön zu wissen, dass es,
aktuell vierundsiebzig derartiger Verfahren gibt äh oder derartiger Konflikte gibt zwischen EU und Deutschland
bestimmte Gesetze angehen, äh die in Deutschland gültig oder nicht gültig sind oder was auch immer, die gegen irgendwelche EU-Richtlinien verstoßen. Darunter zum Beispiel das VW-Gesetz, VW-Gesetz,
betraf damals die Umformung von Volkswagen in eine Aktiengesellschaft,
wo quasi gesetzlich verankert ist, eine Sperminorität für das Land Niedersachsen. Das heißt, sie haben zwar nur etwas über zwanzig Prozent,
Aber niemand anders kann, egal wie viele Aktien er kauft, mehr als zwanzig Prozent Stimmenanteil bekommen.
Früher hieß das Volkseigener Betrieb. Genau.
Genau, heute heißt das halt Sperminorität,
sodass das Niedersachsen egal was ist wenn ich jetzt achtzig Prozent von Volkswagen kaufe kann ich nicht über kann ich nicht über Niedersachsen Anteile stimmen.
So eine Spermiorität ist äh verstößt aus aus relativ offensichtlichen Gründen gegen die Prinzipien des freien Marktes,
niemand, keine Heuschrecke kann sich jetzt äh Volkswagen kaufen, das war ja auch der die Idee hinter diesem Gesetz
da gibt's zum Beispiel anhängige Beschwerden und und Konflikte, ja? Und und noch dann dreiundsiebzig weitere. Insofern diesen einen mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, der macht den Kohl dann nicht fit,
Ähm,
Was gibt's sonst noch zu der zu der Sache zu sagen? Ach ja und gerade kriegte ich dann noch die äh Pressemitteilung des Eco rein,
Eco, das ist ja der äh Providerverband, kann man ja so einfach vereinfacht sagen.
Also nicht nur Provider drin organisiert, ne, der Internetwirtschaft, glaube ich.
Genau, hatten wir nicht sogar schon mal äh da wir hatten den Verband der deutschen Internetwirtschaft hatten wir schon mal auch die Mitglieder teilweise so ein bisschen hier,
Eco sagt jetzt äh ja schönen guten Tag übrigens ähm die Einführung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
verursacht mehr wirtschaftlichen Schaden als Strafzahlung an Brüssel
Was ich eine äh sehr interessante äh Argumentation finde. Man könnte also sagen, die Strafzahlung an Brüssel könnte man als sowas ähm interpretieren wie den,
ähm wie so eine Art Bailout äh für unsere systemrelevanten Provider,
Ja und dass man also sagt, komm dreißig Millionen oder was da jetzt für Zahlen da, da wird ja auch so viel ähm so viel rumspekuliert. Ja, bis jetzt halt ist noch nicht mal irgendwie eine Klage anhängig, ja? Und äh steht jetzt schon in jeder Zeitung, wie viele Millionen da irgendwie eventuell.
Macht sich immer gut, ich meine das ist wahrscheinlich auch das, worauf der Friedrich gesetzt hat, ja? Er hat wahrscheinlich einfach,
weiß nicht, ob er das wirklich geglaubt hat, aber zumindest hat er darauf gesetzt, dass er eben diese Auseinandersetzung
in der Öffentlichkeit verschärfen kann, sondern nach dem Motto am Ende wird die FDP oder in dem Fall Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger keine andere Chance haben, als sich da
einzuknicken, weil es geht ihnen ja sowieso schon so schlecht und dann wieder Jett in Nazar. FDP ist Leasing Story, wobei das,
umgekehrte Jahr sozusagen, eigentlich äh die Wahrheit darstellt und nicht,
weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt für diese Intention war, so stellt sich mir das ein bisschen dar und mich wundert das jetzt auch nicht, dass er damit auf Granit bei ist, weil ich denke, wenn bei Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrener, ich glaube, die geht,
Das hat sie auch schon mal gezeigt, dass sie das kann. So, sie kann jetzt sowieso mit nichts anderem rechnen im nächsten Jahr, als das ihre äh Amtszeit vorbei ist. Ich denke, sie wird sich das jetzt nicht mehr dann nicht mehr die Butter vom Brot nehmen lassen. Da musste sich schon eher feuern lassen.
Vor allem nicht, wenn der äh wenn der Friedrich dann auch noch irgendwie seine Hausaufgaben nicht macht, ja.
Ja ja genau, also auch noch so unprofessionell agiert, ne.
Wobei jetzt also äh vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz diese dreißig Millionen mal ins ins äh rechte Licht gerückt. Ja, das wären bei achtzig Millionen Bundesbürgern pro Jahr,
Äh siebenunddreißig oder achtunddreißig Cent ungefähr, ne?
Ähm gerne, ja, also da zahle ich für meine Nachbarn noch mit. Ja, das ist äh,
das wäre jetzt wirklich nicht, das ist eigentlich keine Summe, ne? Also für für das Geld muss man wahrscheinlich tatsächlich äh dem Eco Recht geben, für das Geld kriegst du nicht pro Person
ähm eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung über sechs Monate äh aufgebaut für die gesamte Bevölkerung. Wenn du das dann mal auf äh pro Person rechnest, ne?
Na ja, äh so viel also da und äh können wir also erstmal äh jetzt gespannt der Dinge harren, die da kommen werden.
Kurzer Nachtrag, den was erwähnt ist, wo wir schon mal über ein Eco gesprochen haben und Mitgliederstruktur et cetera und der Studie sofort, Datenspeicherung, das war Lokbuchnetzpolitik, Ausgabe siebzehn, Corduba zwei null.
Au
Könnt ihr gerne nochmal reinhören und unsere Kapitel zwei anfahren. Beziehungsweise nicht Kapitel, na ja, halt das passende Kapitel. Thema zwei.
Und dann fällt mir gerade noch ein, dass das las ich dann heute auf Spiegel, dass irgendwie unser lieber Freund Hans-Peter Uhl,
Der heißt auch Hans Peter, oder? Ich komme da immer mit an Ude.
Den staunenden Spiegel äh.
Schreibern äh diktiert, ja äh das machen wir dann einfach demnächst hier ohne die äh Justizministerin
Glaube, das Zitat war da irgendwie, äh dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kommt, dass pfeifen die Spatzen von den Dächern, die Frage ist, ob mit oder ohne Sabine, Sascha Schnarrenberger, wer weiß, was er damit wieder meint, aber besonders äh
Gut, also den Mann sollte man eh jetzt nicht mehr ernst nehmen. Das ist ja inzwischen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sich Angela Merkel das erlauben kann, sie zu feiern.
Warten wir's ab. Also ich fand's jetzt erstmal ganz interessant, also zumindest diesen diesen
bei genauerer Betrachtung einfach auch zu sehen, dass sich da der Friedrich auf die Nase gelegt hat. Jetzt mal aus äh Perspektive von CDU-konservativen. Ja, die hätten also derjenige, dem sie jetzt irgendwie eigentlich,
eine knallen müssen, ist ihr Friedrich da, weil der ist halt derzeit verpennt, ja? Also wäre der mit einer mit einem ausgereiften Vorschlag.
Vorbereitung in diese Sache reingegangen. Ähm.
Wer weiß, wie's dann gelaufen wäre, ja? Aber wenn der noch nicht mal ein Vorlage fertiges Ding da hinlegt, dann braucht äh kann jeder sich mit ihm an den Tisch setzen und sagen, hör mal, komm doch einfach mal, was willst du hier für einen Kompromiss machen, wenn du noch nicht mal irgendwie was Fertiges hast? So, komm mal, mach mal und,
kannst ja mal kommen, ja? Ne, aber so.
Mach mal Punkt.
So doch nicht, ne? Ja gut.
Und jetzt habe ich äh das das nächste Ding, da habe ich ja gerade Vollmund eine vollmundige Ankündigung auf auf Twitter getätigt, dass ich ähm jetzt das Unmögliche erreichen werde und den den Gamer YouTube-Konflikt,
erklären werde,
und äh sogar noch das äh Gerichtsurteil, was da jetzt in vom Landesgericht Hamburg Landgericht, äh wie war das nochmal Landeslands vom Gericht von diesem Gericht in Hamburg?
Land Landgericht.
Bundesgericht Oberlandesgericht.
Nee, das war ja nicht das Oberlandesgericht, deswegen ist es ja Landgericht. Also.
War das Landgericht. Er ist nachhaltig verwirrend auf jeden Fall.
Hamburg, ähm da jetzt ein ein Urteil gesprochen hat und ich und ich habe mir vorgenommen, das jetzt zu erklären. Also ähm.
Mal kurz zusammenfassen, also GEMA und YouTube lagen im Clinch.
Das will ich ja gerade erklären.
Ja genau und äh das wirst du jetzt erklären. Gut, dann erklär mal.
Also in diesem Cleanser, hier wurde jetzt in Hamburg ein Urteil gesprochen und beide gehen raus und sagen.
Ja Moment, ich wollte erstmal sagen, was dieser Clinch war, das geht grundsätzlich einfach um die Bereitstellung von Content,
Der Musik verwendet, für den die GEMA Vertretungsberechtigt ist. Darüber haben sie sich gestritten und da gibt's ja seit ewigen Jahren auch diesen Auseinandersetzung
Lange Zeit war das einfach immer nur mit
und dann hat YouTube irgendwann Schmerz voll gehabt und wollte sich nicht länger dafür beschimpfen lassen, hat beschlossen, dann lieber die GEMA dafür beschimpfen zu lassen und dann kam halt dieses Jahr.
Genau und haben damit sehr schön den den Shitstorm auf die.
Im Kern ist, Google will durchaus Geld geben, aber die GEMA will mehr und daran, ja, schieben sich bislang immer die Geister und dann kam es konkret zu einer gerichtlichen äh Auseinandersetzung, die jetzt in Hamburg behandelt wurde.
Und das also als allererstes ist zu sagen, dieser Shitstorm auf die GEMA,
Ist natürlich sehr schön von YouTube orchestriert. Das hatten wir auch schon mal in einer vorherigen Sendung erwähnt, weil die GEMA,
muss diese Rechte einräumen und kann sie auch gar nicht verweigern. Also es steht ein sogenannter Kontrahierungszwang für die GEMA. Die GEMA kann YouTube,
erstmal gar nicht verbieten diese Musik zu streamen.
Muss aber dann, also kann aber dafür dann die Kohle verlangen, ja? Aber sie können's erstmal nicht verbieten. Und äh seit sie, seit zwischen YouTube und Gamer seit zweitausendneun keine Einigung mehr besteht, strollt quasi YouTube die GEMA,
mit diesem äh mit diesem Sperreding, ja?
Und in Wirklichkeit, wie du gerade schon sagtest, streiten die sich um über Gebühren und zwar nicht unbedingt über die Höhe.
Der tatsächlichen Gebühr, sondern die GEMA möchte gerne einen Festbetrag pro Klick,
Erstmal als Basis und YouTube will dynamischer bezahlen, also zum Beispiel die Dauer berücksichtigen und äh die Einnahmen, die Werbeeinnahmen und bietet der GEMA an, äh hier,
Ihr kriegt eine Werbeeinnahmenbeteiligung,
Und das machen die solche äh Vereinbarungen haben die in vierundzwanzig Ländern der Welt. Ja, da wo also die Verwerter Gruppierungen dann,
automatisch an den Werbeeinnahmen beteiligt werden, genauso wie das eigentlich auch der YouTube-User werden kann, der irgendwie ein Video hochlädt, ne, also habe ich da irgendwie auch schon mal so ein so eine E-Mail bekommen,
und ähm die GEMA sagt aber, nee, wir wollen eine abrufbezogene Mindestvergütung.
Und das kommt aber eigentlich aus dem Bereich der bezahlten Downloads,
Also ähm bei iTunes etwas kaufen. Da kriege Pro,
Artikel äh oder Pro äh pro MP3 oder Album oder was auch immer, kriegt die GEMA da einen Fixbetrag. Und da sagt äh
sagt YouTube natürlich, ja Moment, da kauft ja jemand das Lied und und ist ja irgendwie gar nicht zu vergleichen, diese diese Streaming Dienste mit dem, was wir hier machen.
Und dann sagt die GEMA, ja, aber ähm,
Ihr verdient ja auch noch äh Geld mit mit Daten, die ihr über eure Nutzer sammelt, also die Werbeeinblendung ist ja nicht ähm euer einziger Einkunft und und davon wollen wir eigentlich im Prinzip,
Auch noch was haben und deswegen wollen wir äh von unserer Mindestvergütung nicht abholen.
Das ist so der der grobe Konflikt und was normalerweise in einem solchen äh Problemfeld passieren würde,
Was der vorgesehene Weg ist, dass das deutsche Patent- und Markenamt diese Meinungsmaschine zwischen den beiden Parteien schlichtet. Und zwar,
meldet sich YouTube also beim deutschen Patent und Markendamm und sagt hier wir haben ein Problem mit der GEMA,
und zahlt dann den unstrittigen Teil des Geldbetrages, der auf jeden Fall an die Geber bezahlt werden muss, direkt an die GEMA und den strittigen Teil an das DPMA, deutsche äh Patent und Markenamt,
und das verwaltet das quasi als Treuhänder so lange, bis es eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, als Schlichter.
Und sagt dann, okay, hier ist der Betrag äh hier äh Google, YouTube, hier habt ihr den wieder oder nee ähm den gebe ich jetzt der GEMA. So, jetzt ist die Frage, warum geht ihr YouTube nicht zum deutschen Patent und Markenamt?
Und der Grund dafür ist, weil YouTube sagt, wir sind kein Content-Provider,
wie iTunes, sondern wir sind ein Hoster, die Videos mit diesem oder die Musikvideos, um die es geht, die stellen wir da ja nicht rein, sondern unseren Nutzer.
Und deswegen geht YouTube auch hin und sperrt prophylaktisch.
Weil sie den äh GEM-Tarif für Werbefinanziertes Musikstreaming äh nicht bezahlen wollen.
Und sagen deshalb sperren wir diese Videos, damit wir,
gar nicht erst in die in die Richtung Content Provider kommen, weil in dem Moment, wo YouTube quasi öffentlich ein Content Provider wäre, hätten sie.
Den Kern des Konflikts mit der GEMA verloren. Ähm und deswegen sagt YouTube, wir sind Hoster.
Und unterliegt damit der Störerhaftung und die GEMA sagt, nein, ihr seid Content-Provider.
Und äh würde sie deshalb dann diesem ganzen Gamer im vollen Maße unterziehen. Deswegen ist diese Frage so entscheidend. So und YouTube sagt, naja, aber wie gesagt, wir sind kein wir sind,
ähm.
Wir sind nur Hoster, denn wir haben mit dem Content nichts zu tun. Und dann sagt die Geber wieder, ja, aber man guckt euch doch nur wegen der Künstlerin, also ähnlich wie so eine Disco. Ja, das ist also die Argumentation der GEMA. Wenn ich in einer Disco-Leader spiele, muss ich ja auch an die GEMA bezahlen,
weil wenn ich in der Disco keine Musik spielen würde, die Leute im Zweifelsfall nicht kämen. Jetzt mal außen vor gelassen, dass es auch äh,
nur außen vor gelassen, dass es eben auch gEMA-freie Musik gibt, ja? Äh und dann sagt die GEMA und außerdem YouTube habt ihr ja Kontext sensitive Werbung drauf. Das heißt,
ihr macht ja schon wirklich was mit den Inhalten. Also euch ist ja schon, ihr seid was da irgendwie für Inhalte sind, weil ihr entsprechende Werbung schalten könnt. Und so weiter so.
Und es geht also jetzt Täter oder Störerhaftung. Wenn äh YouTube Content Provider ist, dann haben sie die Täterhaftung,
Und wenn sie Hoster sind, dann haben sie die Störerhaftung. Störerhaftung hatte ich ja, glaube ich,
schon in einer Sendung erklärt, das ist dieser Fall, der auch bei einem Blog dann eintritt, in dem Moment, wo ich Kenntnis erlange, dass ich ähm illegale Inhalte verbreite,
oder das über meine Plattform Illegale Inhalte verbreitet werden, muss ich diese entfernen. Also,
Wie bei mega Upload äh oder oder solchen,
oder ich habe einen Nazi-Kommentar in meinem Blog immer, in dem Moment, wo mich darüber jemand in Kenntnis setzt, muss ich das unverzüglich entfernen. Störerhaftung. Ich bin aber nicht,
automatisch dafür verantwortlich. Das wäre Täterhaftung. So und jetzt kommt das Gericht und sagt,
Für YouTube gilt eine Störerhaftung. Sie müssen also unverzüglich löschen.
Und jetzt sagt YouTube, yeah, wir sind kein Content-Provider. Wir haben das Verfahren gewonnen und die GEMA sagt, haha, sie sind verantwortlich und müssen das sofort löschen und nicht erst nach Wochen. Und deswegen sagt die GEMA, yeah.
Hat sozusagen was bekommen.
Jeder hat wertet das für sich als als quasi als Sieg.
Dabei ist es ein Unentschieden.
Dabei ist es ein Unentschieden, ja.
Geeinigt haben sie sich damit ja auch immer noch nicht und die Basis der Einigung. Meine Bedeutung.
Es geht ja noch weiter, kommt noch ein zweiter Punkt. Jetzt kommt der zweite äh das zweite Konflikt ist ähm sagt die GEMA,
Ähm wir wollen aber nicht nur, dass ihr immer, wenn wir euch etwas melden, das löschen, sondern wir wollen, dass ihr Präventionsmaßnahmen ergreift.
Ähm dass YouTube also im Prinzip ist, sagen wir mal idealisiert gesehen, ist natürlich technisch und wirklich ähm komplett verhindert, dass GEMA Musik,
Überhaupt auf YouTube landen könnte, beziehungsweise dass diese nach Deutschland gestreamt wird, solange sie nicht bezahlen.
Ja, das ist ja der, also das ist ja letztendlich das Druckmittel. Eigentlich möchte die GEMA ja auch, dass die Videos bei YouTube gesehen werden können. Sie will nur entsprechend hohen Geldbetrag dafür haben.
Und den hätten sie natürlich auch gerne. Also eigentlich ist auch die GEMA nicht daran interessiert, dass es keine Musikvideos auf YouTube gibt.
Und dann sagen sie halt, also das äh die die Taktik der GEMA scheint da zu sein, okay, wir wollen jetzt eure wir versuchen YouTube die Kosten für die Prävention so hoch zu treiben,
Also für die Prävention, dass sie letztendlich also sagen wir mal das das Maximum wäre ja YouTube hat den kompletten Gamer Katalog äh,
kennt ihn und muss all das verhindern. Ich weiß, er sind irgendwie achtzig Milliarden oder Millionen oder was auch immer, Songs drin. Und das wäre natürlich eine eine nicht zu leistende Aufgabe bei dem Video-Uploadraten, die YouTube hat.
Ja? Und das möchte eigentlich die GEMA, also die Kosten für die Prävention so hoch treiben, dass der Deal mit der GEMA,
Für YouTube attraktiv wird, ja? So und dann sagen sie also, OK, wir wollen also Prävention und dann.
Woher nimmst du das? Das ist jetzt eine eine.
Ist meine taktische Interpretation dessen.
Okay, weil man könnte ja auch sagen, dass sie die Günst der Stunde nutzen wollen und äh,
in dem Moment, wo sie alles automatisch erkennen würden, würden sie ihn auch noch riesen Arbeit abnehmen, ja, weil äh sie sich nicht nur sagen lassen können, ist GEMA, sondern hier ist äh handelt sich exakt genau um das hier.
Genau, also genau, zweiter äh zweiter wichtiger Aspekt gesetzt den Fall, dass die beiden irgendwann eine Einigung hätten würde, ein solches Erkennungssystem es äh der Gamer sehr einfach machen.
Haben die nicht sowieso schon so ein Erkennungssystem? Ich meine, irgendwie müssen sie ja auch diesen ganzen Kram jetzt schon erkennen und,
Es gab ja auch diese absurden äh Fälle, wo ich kann jetzt nicht genau benennen, aber so der Klassiker ist ja so Geburtstagsparty alle singen äh Happy Birthday und weiß.
Hintergrund läuft irgend ein Lied oder so, ja. Genau und das macht YouTube nämlich auch tatsächlich.
Und zwar haben sie zwei äh Techniken, die da offensichtlich zum Einsatz kommen oder eine Haupttechnik. Das ist dieses Content ID. Also sagen wir in dem in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt ein, ich lade ein Musikvideo da hoch und dann kommt, geh mal und sagt, hier äh ist GEMA.
Ähm in dem Moment äh greift ja die Störerhaftung und YouTube muss dieses äh Lied dann sperren.
Und das machen sie, indem sie im Prinzip die Eingangsdatei
bestimmte Analysen unterziehen, also irgendwie sagen, OK, da läuft irgendwie dieses Lied drin, ähnlich wie dieser Algorithmus, indem man irgendwie die Musik erkennt und gleichzeitig kann man ja auch einfach einen hash noch über die hochgeladenen Videodatei und so werfen. Also, machen alles Mögliche,
um das dann zu verhindern.
Aber ähm das Problem ist, dass das nicht funktioniert bei ähm unterschiedlichen Dateien,
und Remixes zum Beispiel. Ja oder oder eine Live-Version, gleiche Lead in der Live-Version kann YouTube dann nicht erkennen. Ja, also der der Kern dieses Streits wäre, also die GEMA sagt, du darfst dieses, wir haben euch doch gesagt, ihr sollt dieses Lied nicht mehr spielen,
Und äh deswegen geht die GEMA davon aus, dass keinerlei Versionen dieses Liedes äh irgendwo gespielt werden mehr dürfen. Während YouTube weiß, okay, diese eine Datei, dieser eine Audio äh teil, darf nicht vorkommen
und nur danach fahren kann. Das heißt, dann eine Live-Version oder so, nicht filtern kann mit den technischen Mitteln.
Und die zweite Möglichkeit ist also dann noch so ein Wortfilter. Also darauf zu achten, wenn das Video heißt, äh so und so GEMA-Künstler singt GEMALID, ähm dass dann dieses Video von vornherein irgendwie ähm.
Ähm gesperrt wird. So und ähm da urteilt das Gericht,
Ähm also um's noch mal zusammenzufassen, GEMA sagt, wenn wir das einmal gemeldet haben, wollen wir das Lied nie wieder bei euch irgendwie sehen und YouTube sagt, naja, wir geben uns doch alle Mühe, aber es gibt Remixes und dann sagt das Gericht, ja, YouTube muss ähm,
Präventionsmaßnahmen ergreifen.
Aber nur für Gemeldete Sachen, gemeldete Interpreten und Titel und nicht für den ganzen GEMA-Katalog. Und auch nicht rückwirkend für den aktuellen Bestand.
Das heißt, ähm letztendlich ähm sagen sie, okay, YouTube muss weitermachen wie bisher, wenn eine Meldung kommt,
Äh müssen sie alles Mögliche äh machen, um das zu um zu verhindern, dass das nochmal.
Wie bezieht sich das auf Remixe? Also das heißt, der Remix muss dann auch noch gemeldet werden oder was sagen sie damit?
Ja, das ist das ist so ein bisschen die Frage. Da sagen sie also, es muss das generell Mögliche muss getan werden,
und ähm vor allem schneller, weil in einem Fall hat's irgendwie bei YouTube sechs Wochen gedauert und das muss also da da urteilt das Gericht, das muss also schneller von statten gehen. Ähm aber,
Der Aufwand soll nicht unverhältnismäßig werden, das heißt oder er muss verhältnismäßig bleiben. Und er ist natürlich bei der Anzahl der Uploads, die da irgendwie stattfinden,
ähm trotzdem enorm, ja. Und ähm kaum zu zu äh zu bewerkstelligen.
Also, Fazit ist,
YouTube geht jetzt also lächelnd nach Hause, weil sie schon mal nicht als Täter haften und ihren bisherigen Videobestand nicht auf Rechtsverletzungen überprüfen müssen. Und die GEMA
lachend nach Hause, weil das Gericht YouTube letztlich doch Filter und Sperrmaßnahmen auferlegt.
Die YouTube aber sowieso im Moment schon ergreift. Also ehrlich gesagt ähm.
So richtig viel ändert sich eigentlich erstmal.
Es ändert sich eigentlich gar nichts. Äh es, es hat sich irgendwie der Status quo äh im Prinzip zementiert.
Und ähm es gibt eigentlich ja das war ja auch schon relativ schnell zu vernehmen. Kein Grund, warum jetzt eine der beiden Parteien ähm da noch Revision einlegen sollte, weil.
Wie gesagt, eigentlich ja beide wollen, dass äh dass die GEMA-Titel dort gespielt werden. Eigentlich wollen sie es ja beide, nur sie sind sich über die Bedingungen nicht einig.
Du willst es doch auch.
Du willst es doch auch, ja? Und sie müssten jetzt auf sie müssten eigentlich mal an einen Tisch, das heißt, letztendlich ist da nicht nicht viel passiert, aber die, die Details dessen finde ich ja schon ganz interessant, ja.
Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt verstanden wurde.
Ja, ich fand das äh eine sehr schöne Zusammenfassung, Linus.
Habe ich, bin ich jetzt auch ganz ehrlich, in diesem Fall muss ich wirklich auf die Links, die ich auch unten drunter angegeben habe, verweisen. Ganz viel
also ich hab unendlich da viel dazu gelesen alle Artikel die ich irgendwie finden konnte und derjenige der mir dann letztendlich geholfen hat war der von Fabian Rack auf Telemedikus der hat's nämlich einfach mal erklärt. Letztendlich hab ich grade einfach seine Analyse wiedergegeben.
Ähm.
Zu verlinken.
Und dann zwei äh wichtige Texte bei Info, wo nämlich einmal äh ein GEMA Vertreter äh im im Interview war und einmal die YouTube-Vertreterin im äh im im Interview war
und dann auch jeweils ihre ihre ähm.
Sichtweisen da.
Sichtweisen dargestellt haben.
Und nächste Woche ist Republika.
Nächste Woche ist Republika und äh das bedeutet, dass äh wir mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß ist, aber wir wollen uns zumindest äh äh bemühen, vielleicht eine Sendung von der Republika zu machen. Das wird dann geklappt haben oder nicht, aber wenn ihr Interesse habt, äh und äh wenn ihr vielleicht sogar auch vor Ort seid, dann äh checkt.
Gib mir doch mal ein Bier aus.
Genau, checkt doch einfach mal hier unseren äh Twitter äh Account, ME Unterstrich Netzpolitik, da äh halten wir euch ja ohnehin äh auf dem Laufenden, was hier neue Veröffentlichungen betrifft und da werden wir das dann auch entsprechend
kommunizieren, wir äh haben den zweiten Tag, den Donnerstag.
Auge gefasst.
Ob das klappt, hängt jetzt noch von diesem und jenem ab. So und dann klappt's oder es klappt nicht. Das war's.
Jo. Bis denn.